this planet what's it called hey
youtubers it's Charlie happy holidays
since there's so much going on this week
between Doctor Who and Sherlock I wanted
to do a special week of programming that
I'm just calling my wholock week so this
video is going to explain what i'm going
to be posting stuff and what its gonna
look like by the way it also happens to
be my birthday this week so if you want
to feel free to send me some good vibes
in the comments below number one here's
what's coming today will be Sherlock I'm
going to try and post new Doctor Who and
Sherlock videos every day but at least
on alternating days so I fed you
Sherlock today then it'll be Doctor Who
tomorrow and so on and so forth with the
exception for Wednesday number two since
Wednesday is Christmas Day i'll be
posting my review of the doctor who
christmas special and a review of the
sherlock mini episode many happy returns
because only people in the UK will be
able to watch that Sherlock mini episode
first I'll be careful for spoilers in
the video I do for that hopefully
they'll post it on their YouTube channel
so everyone else will be able to watch
it eventually number three on Thursday
there will be a doctor who Q&A video for
after the Christmas special since
hopefully by thursday everyone will have
seen the doctor who christmas special
i'll be taking all your guys questions
and answering the best ones in a video
so once i post my review of the
christmas special post all your comments
for the Q&A in the comments for that in
addition to that Q&A video I'll also be
doing a long break down video just like
I did in my 50th anniversary easter eggs
video as well as a couple other videos
especially for a Peter Capaldi and
looking into series 8 the rest of the
week will just be bonus videos for
Sherlock and Doctor Who just alternating
number for Sherlock series 3 in the
videos I'm gonna be posting i'll be
posting each of my sherlock episode
reviews right after they air in the UK
since most people will not be able to
watch sherlock until it airs in the
united states on PBS i will be posting
very clear very careful spoiler warnings
and I'll try not to be too spoilery in
those review videos here's the schedule
for the Sherlock review videos in case
you do want to watch them my episode 1
review will post on january first my
episode 2 review will post on the 5th
and my episode 3 video for the finale
will post on the twelfth just to repeat
there will not be a ton of spoilers in
those review videos I'll be doing the
exact same type of breakdown in Easter
Egg videos and Q&A videos after they
start airing on the 19th in the United
States number 5 explaining those
Sherlock bonus videos I'm going to wait
until after the episodes start airing on
the 19th start posting a lot of my bonus
videos especially the Q&A videos I will
be doing a Q&A video for each episode of
Sherlock so after you watch it you'll be
able to ask me questions and I will
answer them in a video the Sherlock
easter egg videos will post a little bit
earlier too but those will also have
very clear spoiler warnings in case you
haven't seen the episodes yet don't
worry if you're still confused about how
it's all going to work just ask me
questions in the comments below and I'll
be happy to answer them in addition to
all the wholock awesomeness that's
happening this week I'm going to be
posting some more bonus videos your end
stuff and some best of lists for a lot
of the other shows i do as well as some
of the other things that I thought were
really awesome this year that I didn't
necessarily have time to do videos for
before be sure to subscribe to get all
those videos right now you can click
here to get my first one it's going to
be a Sherlock video and you can click
here to get my top eleven Matt Smith
moments thanks so much for watching
Geronimo high fives the game is on